[Musique]
plus de 1000 collégiens appartenant à 45
établissements se sont réunis le 7
octobre dernier pour le challenge
sportif départemental des collèges
organisé en partenariat avec l'UNSS et
la mairie de Saint-Denis cette troisième
édition a été accueillie avec succès par
les jeunes qui ont pu le temps d'une
journée se mesurer dans différentes
épreuves sur le site du complexe sportif
de Champfleury
donc on a un dans le sud dans le sud il
y avait un dans l'Est anniv dernière à
Saint-André et cette année on l'a fait
un dans le Nord nous sommes bien ici
même à souffrir en fin de compte la
justice si vous voulez bien c'est toutes
les des élèves sont gagnants il n'y a
pas un élève qui est plus complot qui
sont en train de motivé les jeunes à
faire du sport toute la journée
l'écollégiens ont enchaîné les épreuves
sportives dans l'espoir d'arrivée en
haut du classement à l'heure de la
remise des prix les 25 premiers collèges
ont été récompensés avec une dotation
mais un seul à gagner le droit de
soulever la coupe le collège Émilie Hugo
de Sainte-Clotilde
[Musique]